I have to hand it to Piers Morgan last
week it was Carrie Lake and this week
it's George Anthony devolder Santos who
show up and they get absolutely
brutalized by Piers Morgan this is
really fascinating stuff George Santos
the lying Republican Congressman to his
credit he showed up clearly having
received some media training over the
last few weeks you can tell he's just a
little more polished and a little bit
more poised but still horribly dishonest
he agreed to take questions from Piers
Morgan and uh it is absolutely
fascinating to see this in this first
clip George Santos defends his lie about
being Jewish by saying it's a joke he's
Jewish and that everybody in the past
thought it was funny and this is clearly
a very sick individual I've always made
this as a party favorite joke and it's
I've done it on stages across what's
funny
a Jew no no no not falsely claiming I'm
Jewish I would always say I'm I was
raised Catholic but I come from a Jewish
family so that makes me Jewish but again
it's always been a party favor
everybody's always loud it's been a
party favorite or favor I don't even
know what he's saying not everybody's
canceling me everybody's pounding down
for a pound just because you're not
Jewish
never said I was
I was and I would always say but my
grandparents are Jewish on my mother's
side so I'm Jewish that was always a
joke everybody used to laugh it up guys
don't you know the joke it's so funny I
said it's a room with a thousand people
in November people were hysterically
laughing it was funny to them they loved
it I don't think Jewish people find it
funny but there's another thing here
also which is important to mention which
is
it's different to as an obvious joke in
a room during a live event to say I
consider myself Jewish and make it clear
that it's a joke versus the numerous
statements numerous statements where he
said Jewish lineage my parents the
grandparents Holocaust this these are
two dramatically different things or do
you wish I was in a room with the
Republicans people find it funny that a
U.S congressman he's a Catholic with no
apparent background of any Jewish
Heritage whatsoever other than you say
you have it no one can find it I think a
lot of Jewish people would find that
offensive I I begged it for when we were
at the RJC in November well no no no no
no it's obvious that Jewish people find
it offensive and it's become abundantly
clear he's like no nobody finds it
offensive at all uh nice job there by
Piers Morgan pointing out the Absurd
absurdity of this
um the other fascinating moment from
this interview
was when George desantos George De
Santos
oh boy that that is quite a Freudian
slip George Santos
um
George desantos George Santos says the
Republican Party basically made him
fabricate his background in order to
like be taken more seriously or
something like that
I was this my family with this father
and it was all untrue so I don't
categorize these as mistakes I think
that part of your process of cathartic
process of redemption if you like it's
going to start from I've been a terrible
liar I mean would you be prepared to say
that sure well like I said well I've
been a terrible liar on those subjects
and and what what I tried to convey to
the American people is
I things that were untrue is what he
tried to convey made mistakes of
allowing the pressures of what I thought
needed to be done in order to this
you guys did you see that his mistake
was he let his misunderstanding of
pressure to say things that weren't true
make him lie like it's this is like an
as I apologize if people were offended
this wasn't about tricking anybody this
wasn't about just it's it's sexy no no
no no no no let me finish about tricking
let me finish it wasn't about tricking
the people this was about getting
accepted by the party right he had to
lie because otherwise the Republican
Party wouldn't accept him
um now sadly this is all sort of part of
the George Santos Rehabilitation tour
and it's becoming increasingly clear
that if nothing changes he's going to be
able to stay in the House of
Representatives he'll probably serve one
term and then be soundly removed he is
off of all of his committees it will be
a meaningless term but it is
increasingly looking like he's going to
be able to say but don't worry everybody
because he's decided he's not going to
lie anymore now here was an interesting
revelation
he says
in terms of why did you think you could
get away with it he says I ran in 2020
and told the same lies and no one
noticed that they were lies then he
never got a Masters in Business at New
York no no like I said no right
I mean again did you not think people
would find this out you know Pierce not
after I you're not wanting to be like a
reality TV no no I understand you know
if you if you were going on Celebrity
Apprentice which I went on right it
doesn't matter you can embellish stuff
about yourself nobody cares right but to
run for Congress of the United States
and to
just tell blatant lies about even your
academic record I'm just struck not
necessarily that a politician would lie
but that you would think no one would
find out well
I'll humor you this I ran in 2020 for
the same exact sake
um for Congress and I got away with it
then and I guess
why well that's honest stupid so you
thought actually they don't they're not
gonna find out no I don't think so
so he's like I told the same lies two
years ago and nobody uh nobody noticed
and then um asked about if he knew that
there would be this Firestorm would he
even have run for office and he says no
I would not are you dealing with the
complete loss of your anonymity now must
have been like for you to be George
Central summer streets in America well
it's it's uncomfortable uh think about
it this way just last night he's the
real victim guys hey we uh my husband
and I went out to the movies and you
know as I'm walking from getting the
tickets to get to the concession stand
to get to the theater that's your that
it Whispers all across the movie theater
so it's just very strange you know
because part of you like it as much as
part of he finds it uncomfortable I
can't stand it and a lot of people think
I love it I just can't stand it it's
something I'm going to have to learn how
to deal with because as as you said
earlier when we were talking uh before
taping once that Genie is out of the
bottle right you can't put it back in so
you need to learn how to live with it
and just that's what I'm doing if you
know what was what a tough victim huh
going to happen to you in terms of the
ferocity of the attention you know
you're currently you've got eight
different official investigations into
you you know people have called you the
biggest liar in the world you know all
this stuff
if you'd known what was going to happen
would you have still wanted to run for
office absolutely not
yeah so there it is he would not have
run if that was the case that he knew
this was going to happen so listen the
interview is pathetic he's clearly been
coached to some degree about how to
answer some of these things he's
strategically you know saying I was
wrong about this I was wrong about that
but but still kind of saying I was
forced into all of it and these were
embellishments and all of this sort of
thing
but he's going to be allowed to stay it
seems to me I believe that he has
weathered the height of the pressure and
I I would love to keep pressuring him
and I will but I don't think it makes a
difference if it's me doing it it seems
as though the
um Storm Is Passing and he'll kind of be
allowed to ring linger Without Really
accomplishing anything until he's voted
out in 2024 would be my guess one of our
sponsors today is mosh whether you're at
the gym on the go between meals mosh
protein bars are the smart snack to keep
your body and brain fueled there's six
delicious flavors like blueberry almond
crunch peanut butter chocolate Crunch
cookie dough crunch each mosh bar comes
packed with 12 grams of protein six
grams of fiber but also important
nutrients like vitamin B vitamin D
Omega-3s and only one gram of sugar and
160 calories I've tried tons of
different protein bars really you can't
beat the taste and the texture of mosh I
love these my favorite is the chocolate
Crunch simple satisfying now that I'm
back in the gym I'll snack on one of
these after a workout mosh is also a
mission-driven company with a portion of
all proceeds donated to support women's
brain health research through the
women's Alzheimer's movement at
Cleveland Clinic mosh is giving my
audience 20 off plus free shipping on
your first six count trial pack go to
moshlife.com Pacman the link is down
below